ومن الجنوب الى الشمال في السعوديه حيث
اليوم كاميرا صباح العربيه ترصد الضباب
وهو يغطي قمه جبل اللوز في ظل التوقعات
الارصاد بتساقط الثلوج مساء اليوم
[موسيقى]
جبل اللوز في اليوم ينضم الينا مراسل صباح
العربيه هاني الصياد هاني اهلا بك من بياض
قلبك نحن كل مره عم نستقبلك في اليوم وفي
جبل اللوز تحديدا تقصد الثلوج هناك
في جبل اللوز من الاسبوع الماضي في انتظار
الثلج ولكن ان شاء الله يعني هناك توقعات
كبيره انه مسائل اليوم واا ويستمر حتى يوم
غد في تساقط الثلوج ولكن في هذه اللحظات
الان كاميرا صباح العربيه
ترصد الضباب على قمه جبل اللوز في درجه
حراره منخفضه جدا تصل الان الى اكثر همم
او تلامس الدرجتين المئويه طبعا قمه جبل
اللوز في النوم وعلى ارتفاع اكثر من 2000
همم مثل عن سطح البحر طبعا تغطيها الان
الضباب هناك كانت طبعا تحذيرات وايضا
التنبيهات قدم من قبل الارصاد الجويه
السعوديه من تساقط والثلوج وكذلك تغير في
الحاله المناخيه همم من الضباب الى ايضا
امطار غزيره سبقت الحاله الضبابيه كانت قد
شهدتها منطقه نيوم خلال الاسبوع الماضي
حتى صباحي او حتى مسائي يوم امس همم طبعا
همم الكاميرا العرب كاميرا صباح العربيه
امم ترصد هذه الحاله اليوم كباقي المناطق
في السعوديه وكذلك باقي الحالات المناخيه
التي الان تمر بها العالم لكن همم لان يوم
قد تكون مختلفه تماما الواقعه في شمال غرب
السعوديه والتي ايضا تستعد بحلول 20 همم
29 بان تستضيف دوره الالعاب الشتويه همم
الاسيويه والتي تستعد لها اليوم بان تكون
هذه المنطقه منطقه كبرى ومنطقه مختلفه
تماما وهي منطقه المستقبل بالنسبه
للسعوديه لعلنا نشاهد ايضا هذه المشاريع
التي تقام الان في ظل هذه الحاله الضبابيه
التي تشهدها همم
قمه جبل اللوز هنا في اليوم وايضا استمرار
عمل المشاريع استعدادا
لهذه الاولمبياد في 20 همم 29 طبعا
سلوج بكره بتشوفوني اشيل الثلج شيل يعني
ان شاء الله الاسبوع الماضي ما تحققت ولكن
ان شاء الله راح تتحقق مع اول حاله مناخيه
للعام الجديد
وشكرا جزيلا هاني كمان من فريق صباح
العربيه بشكركم انت والمصور على الفيديو
الرائع اللي بعثتوا لنا اياه بتقنيه تايم
لابس على الضباب في جبل النصر
يعني ما شاء الله كانوا قاعد يعني يقصدون
الضباب من ساعه الصباح الاولى حتى هذه
اللحظات يسعد صباحكم يعطيكم العافيه
[موسيقى]